[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zu einem blockbuster
ist diese wirklich wusste also wir haben
uns im dezember überlegt er jede woche
zusätzlich zu den zwei rezepten kommt
ich hoffe und die idee ist dass ich in
jedem block also ende des lok etwas
geschockt
die 200.000 abonnenten der auf unserem
youtube kanal haben wir diesen sie
gedacht vor drei jahren dass wir drei
jahre später das ist einfach 200.000
menschen sind die uns zu holen
das war die prognose ende des jahres
knacken wir die 200.000 hockey challenge
teil
es ist jetzt 14 14 durch und denke ich
viel kopiert wenn ich habe jetzt sage
und schreibe ich habe zwei stunden zeit
muss man klarkommen ich mir bewusst dass
ich voll getötet habe also es ist heute
samstag feiern nach herrn das
rentnerdasein meines vaters mein vater
ist jetzt rentner geworden so früheren
dass wir gleich mit der familie gefeiert
da geht noch was essen und später noch
bei uns zu hause ein bisschen gemütlich
sitzen und ich habe jetzt zwei stunden
zeit eventuell zwei torten zu machen
weil nicht nur dass mein körper rentner
geworden ist meine schwester ist
lehrerin geworden und da habe ich mir
gedacht und so ein kleines örtchen für
sie wir auch noch ganze zwei stunden
zwei torten ich habe noch nichts
vorbereitet und dann muss ich noch
irgendwie mich fertig machen und noch
das geschenk einpacken und dann
losfahren meinte ich hab das schon okay
jackpot ich habe noch einen gefrorenen
tortenboden bei mir im tiefkühler gehabt
tortenböden vorbereiten wollte einfach
lass dir auskühlt wickelt sie in
frischhaltefolie ein und dann ab in den
tiefkühler damit und jetzt ein bisschen
rausgeholt und dass sie das mal auftauen
ich hoffe dass es schnell geht
[Musik]
einfach wir bekommen eine richtig schöne
jagd geschenkt und zwar eine die einfach
perfekt ist im winter und richtig warm
hält weil ich finde mal geschenke müssen
einfach sinnvoll seien in erster linie
verpacke ich das noch schön dass ich
jetzt die online bestellt die kam jetzt
in diesem karton an dass man hat mir
einfach gedacht wer den karton jetzt mit
ein bisschen geschenkpapier am morgen
wickeln damit er ein bisschen schöner
aussieht und dann kommt die jacke danke
da zurück
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt keine ahnung was machst
du ich kann nicht mehr
c'est la vie ist es einfach nur schlecht
und packen ich nicht
[Musik]
jetzt geht's vom essen zurück in die
alte wohnung die lange vermisste mich
eigentlich zu hause
okay ein bisschen ist gut dass sagte
führich
für mich beginnt ihr aber wir haben noch
bei ja geboren
[Musik]
goldammer
wir sind jetzt wieder zu hause und wir
haben schon zehn vereins daher
verabschiede ich mich für heute jetzt
schlafen und wir sehen uns im ok in
alter frische
[Musik]
jetzt haben wir gerade unsere 200.000
das special abgefilmt und die balance i
kann die ruhig noch ein bisschen stehen
habe ich mich richtig kurs über 1000
ich gebe es heute sogar werbefrei
heute habe ich auch noch großes vor wir
wollen nämlich eine freundin überraschen
die sich erst kürzlich verlobt hat dafür
mache ich jetzt noch eine süße kleine
torte
[Musik]
überraschung gelungen
so habe ich gerne gekocht leute hier
wohl bewusst meinem messer alle ehre
werden so jetzt schauen wir mal hat das
video abend geehrt hamza letzten weg
haben sie es auch nicht da das heißt ich
habe jetzt hier sturmfreie bude könnt
ihr zu machen und tun und lassen was ich
will aber ich weiß nicht was ich tun
soll
wer reden kann ich ja nicht gucken weil
haben sie und ich gucken serien
gemeinsam
man ist ja immer voller verrät habe man
eine familie weiter um den anderen aha
gucken ob es hier irgendwas für mich zu
tun gibt hier gibt's noch ein bisschen
was für mich zu tun aber die
spülmaschine läuft noch zu mir sind die
hände gebunden also die frau war gerade
hier der wiese des praktikums nach party
organisiert und ich war natürlich dabei
ich durfte ich dabei sein
wer kommt erzähl mal von meiner abend
das wasser schon mit sturmfrei hier habe
ich auch wirklich steckt nämlich raus
geschickt und habe so ok heraus damit
ich will dass meine eltern gefahren und
wir daraus essen gefahren und
sowjetunion wo warst du denn essen bei
der traum kuh aber der traum vom
paradies
so steht's im bad macht mir mein gesicht
sauber zähneputzen petermann ab ins bett
ich bin so müde und ich werde euch am
morgigen montag noch mit also das letzte
mal wochenende quasi also weiligmann
gute nacht und bis morgen
guten morgen liebe gut morgen hamza
was wir denn jetzt gedreht hier so war
ja das ist richtig cool aus spricht sich
kohl die schoko bomben sind jetzt offen
und ich trinke die flasche leer
kennt ihr das da kommen dann schaffe ich
euch ein glas spülen ich schaffe die
ganze flasche und was essen wir zum
wieder werden heute auch wieder stellen
und tagtäglich die frage was sollen wir
heute kochen ja wohl schon fleisch
aufgetaut machen wir hier noch ein video
und zwar müssten auch irgendwas essen
und ich habe mir gedacht ihr wolltet
immer total gerne wieder mal türkische
rezepte deswegen gibt es kräfte auf eine
art und weise wie es glaube ich noch nie
gesehen doch ehrlich ich hoffe du
sowieso nicht weil du eine zubereitung
mir angeguckt weil sie mal gemacht habt
aber da ist mir drin aber dass die
schotten heben wollten gerade drehen und
dann ist die weltuntergangsstimmung
aufgefallen draußen müssen sich
vorstellen wir haben macht
30 bis 16 30 uhr und trifft schaut mal
da wird man hier richtig dépré so
richtig also geht man richtig de priol
bis hin heißt es winterdepression ade
das kalt kommt eine kasse reißen etwas
davon
das stimmt muss sagen dass ich weg da
ist einfach zusätzlich ab weil die leute
dann sagen ja ich mag ja auch lieber
kamen genau angaben nach mit dem
selbstbewusstsein sagt die eine tasse
davon
dann musst du für so viel davon nehmen
und dann so tief davon
und da machst du so viel das war ja das
volk aber ich liege eben mal alles ab
bei den videos so hilft der haben sie
mir immer mach du darfst ja wo ich ein
bisschen mehr
das ding ist aber auch cool muss man
echte hersteller im shop napoli
übersetzung von kräfte ist echt hinter
paletten dritte politische kraft jetzt
[Musik]
das stimmungshoch geworden
sollte mich ein thema für das foto
vorbereitet und ich hoffe dass wir heute
zu minden das glaube es wird mir schon
reichen ansonsten kommt einfach in die
mikrowelle aber das ist so gut aus was
in rom gelogen die leckersten kräfte die
er je gegessen habe so jetzt noch so ein
küsschen
[Applaus]
glaub für einen kaffee bekommen den
schnickschnack schmuck gegen nicht bist
eigentlich dass hansa immer verliert
absolut immer ab und zu 99,9 prozent
schnick schnack schnuck so nur ein punkt
man muss doch immerzu hamza dankeschön
[Gelächter]
dick eingepackt habe ich das erzählt
dann habe ich das instagram erzählt ich
bin früh durcheinander
wir wollten nur noch ins kino und
wollten uns frauen angucken mit seinem
wichtig eingepackt bei leute ich friere
noch vor dem kino geht euch das auch so
diesmal richtig kalt aber erstmal einmal
die maschine anschmeißen ich verspreche
ok jetzt musste ich mich nur warum
ziehen dann bei dem pulli so die arme
von der jacke gespannt haben weil der
politik einzumischen freude ausreden
frauen ausreden
doch nicht gefallen ich bin gewappnet
fürs kino ein unterhemd zwei pullover
was jetzt mit diesem schon im flur ist
dass ich noch was machen diese sieht
vielleicht aus also auf einen
montagabend 22 uhr ist der film habe ich
nicht so beliebten sie nur kommen soll
wir sind nur gerecht und gibt sie dann
nach hause also der firma echt schön
aber ich muss ehrlich sein
ja der erste besser und ich anzug ersten
bisher haus eines hattricks des handels
der pulli angezogen der eigentlich an
mir gehört soll jetzt kommen wir zur
verlosung ich hab euch ja gesagt mein
dezember lockt gibt es immer eine
verlosung ein ich habe mit haben sommer
so richtig genial ist überlegt ihr kennt
wahrscheinlich schon die zwei produkte
aus dem shop das ist und war silikon
back pinsel und unser schneebesen und
die sind extrem hoch qualitativ also ihr
kauft ihr braucht im leben nie wieder
neuen schnee besen oder neuen silikon
back pinsel kaufen wir haben zwei
nagelneue produkte die noch gar nicht
online sind und zwar gehe das sind das
ist einmal einen länder den könnt ihr
auch zum kochen benutzen und ein
kochlöffeln schöne die so edel
die sehen so hübsch aus ich stehe auf
ein schwarzes kochgeschirr und ein
kofferraum gelegt also ganz kräftig mit
ich weiß nicht was diese band lockte
sondern geht weiter
online sind die tage von eve online
stellen ja also quasi exklusiv würde
ferner aktuell kennt ihr noch nicht
online ich persönlich benutze sie ich
hatte dir wenn er einer farbe schon seit
ungefähr eineinhalb jahren gehört der
videos mal gesehen jetzt sind wir schon
mal gesehen aber in schwarz gibt eben
erst die sind wirklich voller qualität
muss richtig richtig gut ja also ich
kann das so gebohrt haben als typ er ist
wirklich sehr sehr gut in diesen extrem
stabil ihr braucht nie wieder neue und
die sind in deutschland hergestellt von
rose dieses set aus diesen vier diesen
vier koch hilfen aus dem shop und
zusätzlich gibt es noch eine schwarze
kiki schütze und ob also alles los ist
ein schwarz artikel im gesamtwert von ca
50 euro also derjenige der das gewinnen
wird sich extrem an dieser qualität
erfreuen jahre lang also will man die
also auch so wenn wir jetzt einmal bei
uns bestellt wie bestellt die nie wieder
weil ihr die einfach ein leben lang habe
man die extrem hochwertig sind aber was
für euch wichtig ist seit abonnent
unseres kanals hinterlassen blog ein
bisschen nach oben
und was mich interessieren würde ich
würde mal sagen ihr sohn hat mir die
wirkstoffe ja wohl nicht vor irgendetwas
angst also ein codewort hansa jetzt
gesagt um am gewinnspiel teilnehmen zu
können also abnehmen und gleiten und ein
codewort reinschreiben damit wir auch
wissen ob er wollte in den lostopf was
soll das codewort seine komische
schreibt und schreibt als codewort
einfach nur dokumente steckt locken ist
okay und dann schreibt er und ich würde
mich natürlich freuen wenn ihr euch
trotzdem auch so zu äußern und an alle
die kleinen
und wir hoffen dass sich der blog
gefallen hat bis zum nächsten block dann
gibt's jedoch sind ja so schön aktiv
genau also bis dahin tschüss